you
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey here to greet you a beautiful
[ __ ] Friday morning slinging dick and
given how [ __ ] flag he understand me
it's a matter of fact today you're
getting ready cuz Monday he's gonna
plant the flag get your [ __ ] into the
[ __ ] situation you're ready it's all
about the [ __ ] state of mind
[ __ ] how you leave that house he
understand me slob definitely robbers
with his [ __ ] I'm telling you right
now it's a state of [ __ ] mind
understand but besides that the clouds
around the bird said [ __ ] it means
singing today but we still got to go
forward rain sleet snow [ __ ]
tornadoes you gotta stab local Joey in
the [ __ ] heart to stop him and his
[ __ ] mission of death you understand
me
but enough with the chitty-chat it's
time to marry the [ __ ] devil it's eco
sir
if you ain't going that deep into the
diaphragm with the reef route debt
you [ __ ] slippin [ __ ] with my
new [ __ ] cleaner here this one of the
[ __ ] the Vietnamese drew it the [ __ ]
army in Apocalypse Now and they were
going down the [ __ ] can out of debt -
you understand me
but that got nothing to do with us today
what's got to do with us today is love a
little reefer and what we're gonna do to
get to the next [ __ ] step that's the
topic today boy I just like I said we're
from the church was happening now I
don't give a [ __ ] about tomorrow next
week I'm a [ __ ] what are you gonna do
today whose [ __ ] [ __ ] baby's gonna
put in [ __ ] your mouth understand
very way enough with the rhetoric
perennial I go to [ __ ] indigo takes
me to the next level before I wash my
little [ __ ] I'm out here with a [ __ ]
rope I'm Sam
looking like Don Cheech 143rd and
company in a poor [ __ ] Avenue
they we don't here we go here we go this
reef was tremendous here they smoked
this last night when I got back from the
county school I was sitting in my chair
[ __ ] drooling like a mohawk but who
gives a [ __ ] that you chew on at that
time of the night
oh I already had my Amin no smoothly
half a banana that cut on cops I'm about
to Washington [ __ ] a little monkey or a
little [ __ ] CBB off to get the [ __ ]
the muscles greased on the [ __ ] elbow
grease and the heart pumping smoothly
and that's it that's my week and I got
no comedy tonight I got a few shows
tomorrow night Sunday don't forget hero
jr. is that the [ __ ] Viper Room
Sunday night and besides that that's it
I'm at the ice house makes Wednesday
they had the [ __ ] month to open up
Labor Day weekend [ __ ] strong you
understand me Sofia and Hollywood
California area around here whether the
[ __ ] this is
Wednesday night I'm in the ice house and
that's it it's Labor Day weekend next
weekend have you talked to people after
Monday all that bad asses and their
[ __ ] head they're taking about potato
salads and you know we're gonna take
somebody pictures get the [ __ ] out of my
face and you me smoking weed on Labor
Day
blowing smoking uncle's face
I'm smoking weed in the morning I love
the smell of THC in the [ __ ] morning
why as it gets me [ __ ] motivated for
the rest of the day to come out of the
chute to come out the box you could see
up for blocks and blocks
the special is going to be tremendous
next to you [ __ ] because you
make me get up in the morning have the
right man to take my mind until his
darkness [ __ ] places he understand
door the dark places
yes motion [ __ ] Skywalker right now oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] is the ship
CM Punk [ __ ] smoke away made that
video you see P CM Punk boxing this [ __ ]
done what are you gonna do I mean I had
no [ __ ] my Harley what are you gonna
[ __ ] do the most important thing of
the day is that we're here together as a
family snow country for some people
break bread we break [ __ ] bugs she
understand me that's how we [ __ ] do
it so let's get together and great we're
in [ __ ] that me and uncle joy get
together and break [ __ ] bugs okay
that's our [ __ ] entryway into [ __ ]
heaven we're gonna be leading the
[ __ ] butt parade up in there
that's all that matters right there
that's all that [ __ ] matters
[ __ ] write your goals keep your
eyes open
it's gonna be a good [ __ ] weekend
it's gonna be a good floppy or whatever
call up do you start with you you start
treating you
my day is pictur shit's gonna happen in
your day you still gonna have a good day
i rear-ended a Dahlia they [ __ ]
dumped we didn't fall out and starts
blitzing around what are you gonna do
was I mad was i angry [ __ ] no you know
life is you got to give you think
earlier once a week gotta get a little
envelope to the [ __ ] earth that's it
you smile and you [ __ ] move on
understand
the judge might dese's up you guys are
ready to listen to it all [ __ ]
weekend I'm getting do whatever to flip
you down and that's it that's it and
that's that
we'll be back Sunday night at 7 o'clock
I'm the [ __ ] Church don't forget next
Wednesday at the Ice House me flopping
around this still bothers no
expectations tool when I do the Comedy
Store and all those I'm gonna use jokes
and rotation like doing no expectations
I go up there with a [ __ ] nothing
maybe a note just to remind me I'm Sam
but I come a family we don't like notes
in my fancy with Bob makers every time
you gotta know you look at it and you
like that [ __ ] on fire yeah I'm
saying
but anyway have a great weekend with
your families you know I love you
without you guys I have [ __ ] nothing
okay you guys keep me in check and you
made me [ __ ] a better comic a better
human bein cuz I [ __ ] got you guys
when I'm talking [ __ ] you guys check me
I'm saying those days are over
if I say I gotta do a hundred push-ups I
got a dorm you guys got eyes everywhere
besides that I love you stay black eat
your greens smoke your rhythm and all
your being it that you think of my might
a lot being uh sorry that's it I love
your [ __ ] stay black have a
great weekend